RIO ANDERSON: The
point of ballet
is to make it look effortless.
But beneath all of that,
it's the most difficult thing
I could imagine.
Ballet can completely break you,
and it's pretty all or nothing.
INTERVIEWER: When did
you start dancing?
RIO ANDERSON: I
didn't start studying
ballet, seriously,
at City Ballet School
until 14, which is pretty late.
A lot of girls start when
they're like 6, 7, 8,
and I started in level
three with the 11-year-olds.
INTERVIEWER: Did you ever
feel dejected because you
were older, thinking
that you had
to do so much more to catch up?
RIO ANDERSON: So I would leave
the class almost every day
and go cry in the bathroom
before coming back in,
because the 11-year-olds
were so talented.
And it was really
depressing, and I thought
about quitting all of the time.
INTERVIEWER: What
kept you going?
RIO ANDERSON: It's
hard because you don't
see improvement day to day.
But eventually, you
see just a glimpse,
and that feels so when
you can see that you've
accomplished something.
INTERVIEWER: Tell me about
some of the competitions
that you've won.
RIO ANDERSON: This year, we
did participate in the Youth
America Grand Prix.
It's the biggest student ballet
competition in the world,
and I ended up winning
the silver medal.
So I received a scholarship
to the Royal Ballet School.
I was accepted to
Harvard this year,
but I'm choosing to defer.
INTERVIEWER: And
how difficult is
it to get into the
Royal Ballet School?
RIO ANDERSON: I think
it's harder than Harvard.
It's definitely a
dream come true.
INTERVIEWER: You have a very
distinct ritual when it comes
to performance and ballet.
Can you tell me about that?
RIO ANDERSON: So
part of the ritual
for me is a very set routine
for preparing your body.
And in doing such a repetitive
and specific warm-up,
you also get your mind
into that sort of zen zone.
I just sit down, close
my eyes, and then I
rehearse my dance in my head.
Sometimes I'll put in
earbuds, but the music
activates the muscle
memory when you're dancing.
I like to visualize
all the dancing,
go through each step in
my mind, just thinking
about the movements,
and also, really
train to feel them in my body.
You do the ideal in your
head and hope it translates.
INTERVIEWER: What
pressure are you under?
How high are the stakes for you?
RIO ANDERSON: As a
student, each performance
matters so much, because
you just don't have as many,
in the competitions.
You only have one
chance on stage.
It's a lot of pressure.
The visualization is so
important, because it shows me
what I'm going for, what I'd
like the performance to be.
And I get really nervous.
So if my mind goes
blank onstage,
the muscle memory kicks
in, because your body
recognizes what's going on
and what's going to happen.
INTERVIEWER: What lessons have
you learned about success?
RIO ANDERSON: The most
surprising thing, for me,
has just been that
success can come.
When I started and I was nowhere
near the top of my class,
I never imagined any of this.
I really fell in
love with dance when
I discovered classical ballet.
And it's strange, but what
I like the most about it
is just how challenging it is,
and improvement that you see
is directly proportional
to what you put in.
You decide how hard
you work, and you
decide how much better you
get, and it's all on you.
Which that independence and
control is really satisfying.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: I hope you
enjoyed this episode
about Rio's dream of becoming
a professional ballerina
and the rituals that are
helping her get there.
To see more rituals of
extraordinary people,
please click here to subscribe.
And for another episode,
please click here to watch now.
SUBJECT: The ritual of swimming
is so important for me.
Every day my body gets to
be immersed in the bay.
I can't imagine my
life without it now.